colombia endurece las medidas para
controlar el hobbit 19 el presidente
iván duque confirmó desde parís que una
prueba de vacunación contra el
coronavirus era obligatoria para los
mayores de edad la decisión aplica para
mayores de 18 años desde el 16 de
noviembre se exigirá al menos una dosis
pero en diciembre se pedirá el esquema
completo de vacunación la medida
aplicará para eventos presenciales de
carácter público o privado que impliquen
asistencia masiva como en bares cines
discotecas casinos iglesias museos entre
otros la decisión busca establecer que
sectores de la población ya han sido
inoculados ya que muchos ciudadanos
salieron de colombia a vacunarse en el
extranjero entretanto desde el 31 de
octubre niños y niñas entre los 3 y los
11 años empezaron a ser vacunados con el
biológico del laboratorio chino sinovac
esta vacunación tiene varios objetivos
el primero proteger la vida de nuestros
niños de 3 a 11 años que si bien tienen
efectos menores tienen igualmente
riesgos pero también proteger a la
población general los niños
en los adultos todos podemos hacer
cuadros síntomas sintomáticos y ser
transmisores la vacuna minimiza ese
riesgo del contagio según el ministerio
de salud colombiano tan solo el fin de
semana más de 22 mil niños en el país
fueron vacunados contra el sars cop 2 lo
que impulsará su regreso a las aulas
colombia superó el martes la barrera de
los 5 millones de contagiados y registra
más de 127 mil muertes y aunque en los
meses de junio y julio registró tasas
bajas de contagios diarios que hicieron
pensar en el fin de la pandemia el
instituto nacional de salud advirtió que
no es el momento de bajar la guardia ya
que las nuevas variantes del virus
siguen circulando